Wow dare you oh boy that's just the
beginning
welcome to snap six that's right this is
actually a pre-alpha dark souls for
everyone a lifetime I didn't get scared
at all it's almost like the game isn't
scary but everyone in the comment was
like oh you don't play the dark that's
why he wasn't scary okay all right I'll
turn up the light that's fine okay and
I'm not doing it because I like to eat
[ __ ] I'm doing it because it's so
goddamn high okay this is like I cannot
record for more than 40 [ __ ] minutes
until I can't [ __ ] breathe but guess
I can and so learning see and this
goddamn office multi-millionaire goddamn
can't even get an a/c installed I got
the guy come here he's like why don't
you just get a fan all right well I got
a fan okay but I still can't [ __ ]
breathe because of the goddamn light
let's play a level two of this one the
living room looks a little hard okay
sure sure it's a little hard sure buddy
Oh someone there I'm here you want you
to hear me please respond immediately
manemma Jess oh cool okay so I got to
defend myself in here this time that's
cool
maybe I should listen to the
instructions actually ah alright so what
do we got we got a couple options right
I should probably just restart because I
need to actually know how to play the
game to beat it let the games begin
oh it's pause so I don't know how to
unpause it doesn't how do I unpause this
huh okay there we go
alright so so this is their feed okay so
what I'm looking at here oh that's
really cool
I'm seeing through their eyes there's a
little notice and everything this is
just foxy and Freddy here oh that's easy
alright so foxy is gonna make our okay
okay okay and then Freddie's gonna be
like a flame he'll give me there alright
alright it's not the sound of like over
here hello hello or fine we're fine
everybody all right that's good so
are they just walking circles in my
house or should I hear them I'm very
confused
they're in there okay that's the door
isn't it they both arrived to a door
right now at the same time I think there
are my side doors oh [ __ ] okay well what
each animatronic always go through a
specific to work try and identify and
remember where they come from but they
came both at the same goddamn [ __ ]
time where do you hide there's nowhere
to hide where do I hide in the fireplace
do I kill myself like what fan
why would I pause the footage I get it
I pause them not the footage but why
interesting really interesting gameplay
it's a [ __ ] rhythm game I swear to
god this is like a rhythm game like it's
like okay so he's about into that door
so let's pause a lot here so that Fox
that can get a head start okay so now
he's in there we're gonna hide here I
don't know okay that that didn't really
work at all okay so let's let Fox 2 come
first and I'm guessing like Bonnie or
some shits going to come through the
main door
we need to offset their sink or whatever
what are you doing okay
okay
the
okay the Fox is about to come where do
we hide then let's just see if we can
just hide here see if that works
I don't [ __ ] it now I don't [ __ ] that
what am I supposed to tell you mate I
don't [ __ ] know hey fam how you doing
buddy don't don't kill me how you doing
buddy you're looking good
all right see you later it worked okay
cool so we have Freddy now I don't know
what happens to foster to be honest he's
about to walk in the door well just
we'll just be chillin here by the god
damn [ __ ] light listen I would just
take the bookshelf hide behind the
bookshelf hey buddy I'm right here right
here love your eyes hello hello I'm nice
Wow incredible you just check out a tank
on the horse with a rocket life
incredible alright now one hour back at
foxy fam they're both sort of reset okay
we'll pause foxy oh that sound by the
way god I have to look at other stuff ah
that's not good is it ah [ __ ] I'm sure
it's fine I'm sure it's fine let's have
one two three four five okay and I'm
sure that was up alright are you going
to are you going to [ __ ] me or what's
happening here I don't get it where do
you hide if it comes through there okay
Oh God go go go hey fam how you doing
looking good man looking good as always
me
alright get the [ __ ] out
Oh God
I was like should I just hide or go [ __ ]
I don't know about this one this is not
scary
I mean the game is kind of comfortable
you're just sitting on a couch it's
pretty nice man not every day you get
through the privilege of that man
alright Fox 2 coming through soon
all right he's coming through now
it's interesting though it is kind of
cool all right let's look at Freddy how
is he doing my man
Freddy the fingering [ __ ] alright so
he's coming now I'm just gonna be like
fam I'm chilling relaxing Maxon oh cool
hello Oh chick if the weird that I just
want cheek yet to come in and [ __ ] me
that's all I want you know met the Fox
is at it again
back getting it again so we here mr. fam
here go through here and he's like ha
[ __ ] you I'm [ __ ] but I don't know
what to do when he comes I really don't
know maybe you need to stand by one of
the doors okay so it seems we need to
pause from young man just cool it for a
minute fam i
Fox's coming through we'll go here
this is great having a great having a
great time Freddie should be coming by
soon oh god he's really close I don't
know how close until he actually comes
out but I'm guessing I have to hide by
the bookshelf this is a little awkward I
think it's gonna come through any second
[ __ ] [ __ ] I [ __ ] up you're gonna have
to leave really quick because I have
other guests coming soon okay cool okay
so I think this guy's right yeah okay so
we'll go here now isn't that right I
said that's right oh wow I sure hope no
one comes in here I'm [ __ ] close do
you need to get oh my lord that guy
wants to suck my balls hey welcome to
the fam squad fam all right he doesn't
want to be part of a squad fan I'm gonna
have to look at foxy right now cuz I oh
ha ha ha okay I may have [ __ ] up the
timing just a tiny little bit it's hard
there's so many of them [ __ ] man alright
actually let's pause Freddy as much as
possible okay just as much as we can
okay now we have to go though she's
really slow at getting up the couch I'm
thinking I'm an extremely overweight
youtuber whose have stuck in him Nate
with some red red too much fat and a
fanfiction
and Here I am Here I am baby sound theme
delivery let's have a look at my man
Freddy fan
now let's pause foxy as much as possible
okay it's like an ant one two a three
four five six seven eight nine ten okay
I'm fine oh [ __ ] dog it's a really cool
idea this one but it doesn't really have
the horror effect I'm gonna have to pass
him as much one two oh god that does not
sound good
how cool is that we look in here okay
not too bad
welp I will pass him some more I was
Freddy doing spread it at the corner
that's not good
[ __ ] I missed the timing on this one
listen fam shut up like I don't have
time
geez okay he's gonna let me just check
on him okay we're fine we're fine we're
fine
I fam you're welcome Oh got it
you just went closer to me I need you to
leave right away cuz like I have
business to attend Thank You fam now I
do believe Oh God hahaha I'm not good at
these games okay I'm really not come on
come on I can do this I know I can
I'm the best horror gamer on YouTube as
everyone knows just look how scared I am
don't you feel the fear that I'm feeling
because wow just wow
I was fine but fine
oh god we gotta go we gotta go [ __ ]
go to me hey you want to you want to $5
suck you mean come on me okay let's look
here it's all clear math fam easy this
is easy I never played a game so easy in
my goddamn life
easy peasy titty squeezy as I always say
it's my catchphrase everyone knows me
about it
hey Freddie you wanna [ __ ] you wanna
[ __ ] on a soccer come on Freddie
come on boy right here my ass look at it
very nice I know how you doing fam how
we doing here fam all right you you say
well you will stay away from for a while
yeah okay I don't want to get [ __ ] by
your mane all right [ __ ] see I'm gonna
let you [ __ ] see mine come on
[ __ ] it's moving closer isn't he
Oh Oh I got [ __ ] whether you come Oh
chica mica [ __ ] this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] everyone and
so [ __ ] done